All right, Steve Lawson, we're here in a room at the Valley Library, it's the 14th day of November, 2011.
Okay, so today we will principally be talking about the Institute at OSU as a couple of things.
I wanted to pass on sort of a past analogy of our talks that we didn't actually get to.
And the first is an important question.
I think that's if you can sort of trace how you advance into the ranks of executive officer,
and then to the executive officer of OSU.
Sure, that was quite a surprise.
I think in our last conversation, I outlined some of the financial problems that the Institute had been chronically experiencing,
and these go way back to the 1970s, where staff was asked to take pay cuts and the contribution to the retirement plan
was decreased periodically for a set period of time.
So employees in the Institute would know strangers to financial hardship.
And the salaries were not very competitive, fairly low, probably when you compared salaries to roughly equivalent positions in academia,
or in the private sector in that time.
But I think people had a great passion for the UN as part of the Institute, which is why I work there, certainly,
really felt strongly about the mission, and I really like Linus Pauling.
The more I found out about him, the more I liked him, then I was very pleased and kind of honored to be part of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
And as my skills developed in science, and I started to get involved in more and more projects, I found it very challenging and lots of fun.
And I think I demonstrated some aptitude, or I don't think I would have been asked by Pauling and others to participate at the level I was asked.
Then in the mid-1980s, Emil Zukicondo, who succeeded Art Robinson's President Director of the Institute, was getting very interested in using the relatively new technique called two-dimensional polyacryl and my gel electrophoresis to profile proteins that might distinguish
tumor cells from primary tissue, from metastatic tumor tissue.
And we set up a laboratory together and started on a fairly productive collaboration.
And as a result of that, I became co-director of the lab for research and gene regulation and reported directly to Emil Zukicondo.
And Emil and I got along very, very well, I really respected him, extraordinarily intelligent person.
I can see why his collaboration with Pauling was so successful in the early 1960s.
And as the Institute moved to the point of inflection of the decades, their Emil's tenure was coming to an end.
And as I mentioned last time, Emil and Rick Hicks departed from the Institute because I think Emil was unwilling to make some of the changes that the board felt were necessary to align income without go.
So the Institute had expanded pretty dramatically under Emil's direction and had become kind of a broad molecular biological biomedical research organization.
So it had some areas of orthomolecular medicine, but it also had areas that were really not germane to orthomolecular medicine.
That were of interest to Emil specifically and to others, of course, who were carrying out the specific research project at the Institute.
So when Emil left, and Linus Pauling of course had become sick and was not interested in carrying out many administrative responsibilities.
I don't know Linus Pauling Jr. stepped in to fill an obvious void there.
And that began kind of my long association with Linus Pauling Jr. I got to know him very well and I think we worked together very well as well.
I took care of the day-to-day management of the Institute and Linus Pauling Jr.
As a result of his experience in wisdom provided some direction to me as well.
I think I mentioned last time that when the Institute was going through this reorganization, a fate of different research projects and researchers within the organization was really up in the air and people weren't sure whether they would be asked to remain with the Institute or whether they would be laid off.
So researchers whose work was pretty carefully aligned.
Excuse me.
With the newly refocused worth of molecular medical mission,
I felt fairly confident about remaining when the Institute and others were really anxious, of course.
At some point there was a board meeting and there were board meetings more often during this period.
The board meetings had been relatively rare during my tenure at the Institute.
I was never sure exactly when a board meeting was being held.
I think that they were held probably as often as required by law, but not very often.
But during this period of change in turmoil, board meetings were quite regular.
And I remember being, of course, I was unsure about my fate within the Institute as well.
Because the work I was doing was really not related, specifically to worth molecular medicine.
So I was concerned that I might be losing my job.
And I was aware of a meal's imminent departure.
So I obviously was concerned about my future then too.
And it came as a great surprise during a board meeting when I was summoned to the two Linus Plans office where the board was meeting by Dorothy Monroe.
And I had no idea why they wanted to talk to me or what I could offer to the board, but nevertheless I went down and met with the board.
And at that time, they introduced some changes that they had been thinking about and they asked me for my opinion of these changes.
And on the board in the office there, they had somebody had written an organizational chart for the Institute.
And I looked at it and made a few comments and generally thought that I was a good opinion.
I mean, it was a good idea that they had decided to really make clear the responsibilities within the Institute.
Because it was something that was of great concern to people.
Because the Institute had operated managerially as a bit of a black box and decisions were not always clear.
The rationale for decisions were not always obvious.
And I think that's true in any organization, but in the smaller organization it can be, it can cause a lot of problems.
So during the board meeting, they asked me also, I believe if I was interested in participating in the re-organized Institute.
And without giving it much thought at the time, I said, yes, I was a bit surprised and also I think a bit flattered by this invitation to assume more responsibility within the Institute.
And I thought it was likely to be quite a challenge.
At that time I had no idea how dramatic a challenge it would be, but I knew that it would be stimulating.
And like I said earlier, I like to solve problems and I saw quite a few problems and I thought that I might be helpful in tackling them.
So you've had a change in some like those from the executive office of the Institute.
Right, it went through metamorphosis, initially Linus Pauling had asked me to be, I think the title was assistant to the president.
When he assumed very temporarily the role of president.
And I took that job serious, I didn't really know what it entailed, but I took it seriously.
And I started thinking about things that needed to be acted upon at the Institute.
And I think I produced a list of some things that needed to be done and my rationale for doing them and gave that to Linus Pauling.
And he left for a few months to go down to Big Sur.
So there was really a bit of a vacuum.
And I think Linus Pauling Jr recognized that his father, at that time recognized that his father really had no interest in managing the Institute.
And I was left without much direction at that point.
I've been given a new title, but I didn't really have a firm grasp of what I was expected to do.
And I didn't really feel that I had the authority to do what I thought was in the best interest in the Institute, because I was not chief administrator in the Institute.
So my job title changed when in the board we organized the Institute and asked me to become involved in management from that to executive officer.
And I think executive officer has come an old terminology from the military.
And maybe after a year or so as executive officer, I was named chief executive officer.
Was there any significant difference in the power you had or you just want to go into it?
I think it was just a title change.
I think it was just recognizing the actual duties that I was performing at the Institute.
Because Linus Pauling Jr, of course, was still living in Hawaii.
And he would come to the Institute periodically, sometimes as often as once a month or a day or two.
Excuse me, but I was handling all the day-to-day administrative tasks at the Institute.
And also we had litigation at that time and trying to, we were trying to chart a course for the future.
And all those things I was acting on on a daily basis and thinking about and discussing with my colleagues at the Institute in elsewhere.
I believe he became chairman of the board of trustees and Linus Pauling Sr. at some point became director of research.
Which was a little odd because technically Linus Pauling on the board, the board was responsible.
I reported to the board, so I reported to Linus Pauling, but as director of research, he also technically reported to me as chief executive officer.
So it was kind of an odd situation, but it didn't interfere with our relationship or any of our activities because I don't think we'd let titles get in the way.
Another thing that we touched on in our last meeting that I wanted to follow up on real quick.
It was the last one of our foundations.
All right.
I mentioned that in the context of some of the case rapidly involved in that.
What we came with that.
As I mentioned, some of Matthias Ratz activities were unknown to employees in the Institute.
We became vaguely aware at some point that other organizations with kind of a parallel mission to the Institute were being set up by Pauling and Raff.
And that cost a little consternation because we weren't sure if.
And I wasn't in management at that time, but we the employees at the Institute weren't sure if these other.
The organizations were going to be competitive with the Institute, where they're going to compete for funds for the same donors, for instance, or the same organizations.
And at some point it became clear to me that it really wasn't strictly competitive, but I didn't really see the rationale for having independent organizations to carry out this work.
So I believe that Raff and Pauling set up.
The one is putting heart foundation because they were anxious to.
Sort of get around the management of the Institute and carry raise money and carry out clinical trials in.
Vitamin C and heart disease, specifically after a sclerosis and do more investigative work.
Maybe mechanistic work on lysine proline vitamin C and lipoprotein A, which was the main focus of Pauling's research interest at that time.
The North and Milwaukee, the medicine.
But Ratt had as he and Pauling were starting to grow apart because Pauling, I think, was expressing some.
Decreasing confidence in Raff's behavior and abilities.
Pauling decided to wrap up the line is applying heart foundation.
And I believe this was probably after Ratt had left the Institute.
But here was this organization that had an independent life, had headquarters in a small office building in California.
And they're just a few blocks from the Institute and Raff had apparently hired several people to do work there.
So they were on the payroll.
And some of the activities of the foundation apparently were surprised to Pauling because when he was informed about these things,
he was not pleased about some of the activities the foundation ended to take him.
So he asked me if I would wind up the line is applying heart foundation and transfer the assets to the line is applying to the science medicine.
To carry out work and heart disease.
So I told him I'd be happy to do that and said about legally dissolving the line is applying heart foundation.
And taking the physical assets back to the 440 page mail road facility.
And also transferring the financial assets to a restricted account that Pauling is applying to the Institute of Science and Medicine.
Okay, so the last.
At the end of our interview last time we were at the point.
In 1994, you received a couple of please substantial gifts that kept the Institute more or less a lot at the end of the week.
And in 1996, the Institute moved to OSU.
So I'm interested in knowing how that process very out.
Let me back up briefly in 1994.
It was a very pivotal year in many respects not just because of Pauling's death, but it was also the year that we celebrated the 20th anniversary
and we wanted to apply Institute of Science and Medicine.
And we started early.
Let's see, I think it must have been late spring or early summer.
Maybe it was late spring.
Let me see now.
I'm confused about the year.
Was it 1993 or 1993 or 1993 or 1994?
Perhaps it was 1993 when we celebrated the 20th anniversary.
That would have been the appropriate year at Ringstore House in Mountain View, California.
And that was an opportunity for Pauling to see some of his old friends and colleagues.
We invited quite a few of his colleagues from academic institutions and local donors and friends of the Institute.
And of course, the staff, faculty and staff of the line is playing Institute of Science and Medicine in their guests.
So it was a really terrific event at a beautiful renovated Victorian house that was on the mud flats in Mountain View.
And special collections came representatives of special collections here at OSU.
You came down with some of Pauling's medals and awards that he'd already given to the university.
So they were on display and we had posters, scientific posters.
And it was really a great time for Pauling to meet and greet perhaps for the last time some of his associates.
And then in 1994, also to celebrate the 20th anniversary of the line is playing Institute of Science and Medicine.
We decided to convene a large scientific conference.
In the Institute had historically convened a number of conferences.
One was to honor Bjorn Gordonstrom from the Carolinian Institute.
Pauling became quite interested in his biometric theory of cancer therapy.
Quite interesting.
So there was a symposium to honor him.
And then some years earlier there had been another symposium called Nutrition Health and Peace.
convened by the Institute.
We presentations by a whole raft of people doing work in North Molecular Medicine and Molecular Biology and Chemistry.
Again, a little bit to honor Linus Pong's work in North Molecular Medicine Science and Peace.
And of course there had been birthday parties for Linus Pong and the Linus Pong, a work for humanitarianism.
So there have been a lot of events throughout the history of Linus Pong Institute.
Some were the fundraiser and focus and some were the scientific focus.
But of course Linus Pong was always at the midst of these occasions.
So we decided that an appropriate 20th anniversary event would be a conference.
A scientific conference organized around the theme of worth of Molecular Medicine.
And Linus Pong was pleased to hear about this.
And we decided to call it the therapeutic potential of biological antioxidants.
And we had a scientific committee and organized committee set up at the Institute that reviewed poster abstracts and invited people to speak at the conference.
I remember going into Paulings Office to ask him what he thought of our provisional title with therapeutic potential of biological antioxidants.
And in his very characteristic way, he leaned back in his chair and closed his eyes and thought for a minute.
And without even opening his eyes, he said to me, well, I think it's fine.
But we shouldn't forget that molecules like vitamin C serve many functions in the body.
They're not strictly committed to being only antioxidants.
They also have very other important properties.
And we shouldn't forget that.
And I agreed with him completely, but he gave his blessing to our provisional title for the conference.
So he also agreed to be the keynote speaker at the conference.
And this was scheduled for the fall of 1994, September.
And people like Bruce Aames and Balsfri, Brett Traber, Lester Packer, Enrique Cadenas.
A lot of people in the free radical field were there.
And I hadn't met some of these people before.
I'd met Bruce Aames and Balsfri as early as 1989 when they came to the Institute to give a seminar on vitamin C.
Because Aames had published with Fry, a paper in PNAS that year showing that out the score bay is the outstanding antioxidant in human blood.
And a pecking warder, it's number one.
And Polly, of course, was very excited by that paper.
And they were invited to come to the seminar and study the day of the earthquake actually as it turned out.
So there were a lot of interesting people invited to speak at our conference.
And then, of course, Polly died at the end of August.
So I asked Henry Talbe, who was one of Polly's friends,
and had done work in free radical chemistry as well.
If he would step in as a substitute for one as Polly and give the keynote address at our conference.
And he was happy to do so. That was very gracious of him to consent to do that at the last minute.
Because he was very active at Stanford.
And I'm sure there were many demands on his time.
And I thought it was terrific that he really rose to the occasion and agreed to give that talk, which went very well.
I drove him up to Tiberon, picked him up at Stanford and drove him to Tiberon that day to give the talk.
And he didn't have standing job really, really thrilled to group there.
So, after Polly had died, of course, and before his death, we were engaged in analyzing options for the future of the institute.
And I discussed some ideas with some of the people that had attended the therapeutic potential biologically into the oxenance in September.
And then was approached in 1994, in 1993, 1994.
I was also working with a fellow named Bill Camp, who was introducing me to people in different universities around the country.
And we had been talking, as I mentioned last time, with people in all over the place.
Bill had arranged for me to meet the governor of Oklahoma at the Jonathan Club in Los Angeles.
Because the governor of Oklahoma was on a trip, as many governors do, to try to get businesses to relocate,
or move some of their operations to the state of Oklahoma, because that's the economic engine that drives the state.
So, I met with the governor at the Jonathan Club.
It was kind of a funny meeting that was in a really luxurious room at the Jonathan Club.
And the governor was there with his chief of staff, and maybe a dozen or 14 other people.
They were all paying wrapped attention to everything that he said and did.
They were all aligned on one side of a long, long conference table, and it was me.
On the other side of the conference table, I had no people, I had no retinue, I had no advisers, just me.
And I had a great conversation with him, and he invited me and Linus Pond Jr to go to Oklahoma City to make a presentation to the president and the university,
president of the foundation there, which operates in a similar way to the Oregon State University foundation here,
with their relationship to the local university or the state school I should say.
But anyway, getting back to more specifically your question.
Other people came and made presentations to our board about their ideas for relocation.
And one of the people who came was John Bern, who brought with him.
I believe you brought with him, Dick Scanlan, who was dean of research at that time.
And Oregon State University, in many ways, I mean, just superficially seemed to be a good fit,
because Linus Pond was his alma mater.
He'd already agreed to give us, in his wife's personal professional memorabilia, to Oregon State University,
to be housed in a new special collection, this forms her in the nucleus of special collections.
So it seemed like a good fit, but we weren't really sure about the specifically how the institute would work into the program here.
So John Bern and Dick Scanlan talked about the centers and institutes.
There were already extant at Oregon State University and how they were organized and how they reported to and how they were staffed and so forth.
And they talked a bit about the nutrition department and the work that was going on there.
The research size and sports physiology, medicine, pharmacy, biochemistry and bio physics, environmental and molecular toxicology.
Strong programs that seem to have some relevance to the institute's mission.
And that led to, of course, many discussions and meetings between staff at Oregon State University and our staff at the one that's applying Institute of Science and Medicine,
including hosting a meeting between a committee that John Bern had put together to seriously analyze this prospect of the institute,
relocating to Oregon State University, to find out whether it was really a good thing to do or not.
John Lyon, George Bailey, a number of other people were on that committee.
And they came down to Palo Alto and I hosted them for a day and talked about the mission of the Institute and how we had been funded.
Historically, talked a lot about the scientific work, a lot about the fundrais and work.
They weren't really familiar with the term orthomolecular.
So we spent quite a lot of time thinking about that and discussing it.
And I think they came to realize that some of the work that they themselves were doing could be considered orthomolecular,
but they hadn't really applied that term to their own work.
And I think as a result of those many meetings that became clear that there was a good fit between the Linus Poly Institute and Oregon State University.
Although it was untenable to bring the whole institute with all its employees up to Corvallis because there was just too many people.
We had, I can't remember what the specific number of employees was at that time,
but back at before the reorganization, it would maybe 70, 75 people at the Institute,
and then after the reorganization that was dropped down to maybe 50 or so.
And of course, with the Institute moving to Oregon State University, a lot of the administrative functions that we had to assume ourselves in Palo Alto,
we would no longer have to assume.
So we had no need for a controller, a bookkeeper, or we still had need for fundrais,
but of course the fundraising activities were going to be taken over by the OSU Foundation.
So we didn't really need to have a fundraising staff to come with us to Oregon State University.
So we had broad and deep discussions about all those issues.
And the researchers at the Linus Poly Institute of Science and Medicine,
who the Dean of Research and the ad hoc committee formed by John Bern believed had the best chance of succeeding here at Oregon State University.
We're asked to come up and meet the faculty and staff that they might interact with here on campus and the different departments.
And so there were a number of visits between back and forth between OSU and LPSM.
And as a result of that, Dick Scanlon was pretty frank with me about who might really succeed at Oregon State University,
and what might be the most important part of the Linus Poly Institute to bring up to Oregon State University.
And that led to the decision to bring a relatively small nucleus of people about half a dozen to Oregon State University.
Now there were some people that I think could have made the transition had they wanted to,
but they had, for instance, there was one fellow doing work that was supported by a Department of Energy grant at the Institute in Palo Alto.
And his wife was a physician and they had a comfortable life in the Bay Area and they really didn't want to leave.
And the weather people who also were approaching retirement age and decided that it might just be best to retire rather than moved to Oregon.
So there were a lot of factors that came into play in determining who actually moved to Corvalles.
But at the time we had a very, and I mentioned this the last time, a really good,
contractual relationship with Unilever and Elizabeth Arden that was continuing.
So the people involved with that particular project were given offered jobs at Oregon State University,
and a number of other people were as well.
I think there were about half a dozen, six or seven people total.
It was kind of a cavalry who was an Irish biochemist working on the Arden's supported project.
The D. Mivenov, who was working in cardiovascular disease research and his wife, Svetlana Ivanova,
Wahid Rumi, who was doing some really good work in cytotoxic,
trying to determine the cytotoxic moiety of the vitamin C molecule and some of its derivatives.
Myself.
And that could have been it.
I'm the only one left. That's right.
Conor McEvely left after the contract supported work expired,
and that contract had a finite start and stop time.
And then the D. Mivenov and his wife Svetlana decided to return to the Bay Area
because they felt more comfortable in the Bay Area.
They really liked California quite a lot.
The D. Mivenov had come from the Moscow cardiological institute in Russia and found California
just a paradise compared to what they left in Russia.
And I think they just had a terrific fondness for California.
So they weren't willing to become permanent residents here in Oregon.
And we'll heed Rumi left after some time.
We had an interim director at the Institute, Don Reed, who I believe at that time
was director of the Environmental Health Science Center as well.
And a member of the biochemist involved physics faculty.
I was going to ask you about leadership.
Yeah, so he was providing some leadership.
We, one of the first things that we did together was to hire an office manager.
We hired Barbara McVickard. I believe she was the first employee.
Actually, the first employee was Oberthias, who was selected by the Oregon State University Foundation
to become our fundraiser.
So I work quite closely with Ober and the very early days in a prize in him
of some of our fundraising history.
Telling him a little bit about some of the contractual relationships we had
that generated income from the Institute and also some of the charitable foundations
and philanthropies who had been very kind to the Institute over the years
and talked to him about some of our big donors and be quests and so forth.
I worked pretty closely.
Oberthias had been coming down to Palo Alto to go through some of our fundraising files
as well to help him identify what was important to bring up to Oregon State.
And of course, one of the most precious resources that was transferred was our donor database
because Oregon State University, I think, recognized that absent large government grants
it was going to be tough to keep the Institute going without reliance on the contract we had
as ardent and unilever and also sustained giving by our donors.
So that was very important to keep that safe and to cultivate the donors
and that began even before we moved here.
So what sort of commitment did OSU make the Institute identify person?
Well, the commitment was really spelled out in a document that we wrote jointly
called the Memorandum of Understanding, which was signed in 1995
by Linus Pond Jr. myself, Paul Risser, who was the incoming president of Oregon State University.
It really spelled out how the Institute's assets, including financial assets, fundraising assets,
physical assets, and personnel would be transferred here to the campus of Oregon State University
and the Oregon State University Foundation, and how the Institute would go through legal dissolution
and also the expectations for what the University would provide for the Institute in the future,
including, I think, a really key phrase about launching a capital campaign to secure a building
for the Institute as soon as that was feasible.
So right from the get-go, there was always the promise of a building for the Institute
because on any university campus spaces that are premium,
and I'm not sure who had been in the departments.
I think Bob Chemistry and Bob Physics may have been in the initial space that the Institute
occupied in Weniger Hall, but in 1995, after the Memorandum of Understanding
had been executed and renovation of this space on the fifth floor in Weniger Hall was undertaken,
I would come up periodically to work hard with Dick Scanlan and others on the details and logistics
of the move from Palo Alto to Corvallis, including an analysis of the laboratory requirement.
So these laboratories were renovated, they were painted, the wood was stiffed up and polished and sanded
and new countertops were installed, air conditioning was installed because these old labs in the middle
of the building didn't have air conditioning, building wide air conditioning.
And there was an area that was the south part of the fifth floor of Weniger,
which was renovated for LPI.
There were still offices in laboratories there for other departments, oceanography and atmospheric sciences,
to name one, and some other people were still scattered throughout that space.
So it wasn't a contiguous LPI space from the west and around to the east end,
but it was certainly satisfactory for the Institute's initial efforts here at Oregon State.
So the furniture, the laboratory equipment, centrifuges, laboratory supplies, chemicals,
paper, journals, a lot of the material from Palo Alto and Palo Alto was all transferred up,
moved up in August of exceeding July of 1996.
And that was a very, very difficult process because we managed to move ourselves.
We had professional movers, of course, we hired to make this move,
but we had to make lots of decisions in Palo Alto about what should be moved and what shouldn't be moved,
and what could be recycled and what could be thrown away and so on and so forth.
So we filled up two dumpsters a week for well over a month,
which is junk that we had no use for in the future.
And then of course everything was packed securely and brought up here at Oregon State University.
And a lot of the journals and laboratory equipment that wasn't in use,
immediately, was stored in the sixth floor of Weniger, and with some storage on the fifth floor as well.
And then over time, especially after Boltshire was recruited as the director of the Linus Poly Institute here at Oregon State,
and following that, because I think I mentioned once before that when the candidates for director,
that in dad position, came to interview on campus,
I think they all asked the University administration the same question,
which is, what are you going to do to provide for growth for the Institute,
how will the Institute grow?
And I think the University to its credit responded satisfactorily to those questions,
by offering to set up a couple of faculty lines and start up packages for in order to recruit new faculty.
So that was also something that was an incentive and recruiting a good director
that we would have the ability to grow the Institute built in to the initial program.
So as Wen Boltshire assumed that position,
and we set about recruiting new faculty,
the material that had been stored in the fifth floor had to be moved.
And at that time, a lot of the filing cabinets that stored Polling's files and manuscripts and stuff
were moved over here in special collections, excuse me.
And a lot of the other stuff that we perceive no need to keep old journals,
for instance, that the library couldn't use, and we really had no need for
or storage capacity, physically and when are there or were recycled.
So the University did commit this along with funding,
then it wasn't just an issue providing space in saying the floor.
We have a foundation representative, and I'll be raising money,
but we'll, for what will you do to bond by funding the floor?
Well, in the memorandum of understanding that ongoing funding to provide startup packages
and salary lines for additional faculty, that was not part of the memorandum of understanding.
That was something that developed as a result of feedback from interviews
for the director, among the director candidates.
And to be honest with you, because I had not had professional experience
within a university environment, nor had lines upon junior,
nor had the other members of our Board of Trustees with the exception of a couple,
it wasn't something that we anticipated.
So, had we anticipated that we really needed to secure a mechanism at that time
to grow the institute.
We probably would have incorporated that in the memorandum of understanding,
but I think that was an issue that escaped the analysis at that time.
It was only later that that was really addressed.
But the idea for a building from institute was there right from the beginning
because we recognized that the renovated part of when a girl was not going to be sufficient
should the institute be successful.
That wasn't going to be big enough to hold the institute.
And we thought that having our own building would be really a
fitting tribute to one is falling.
And I think John Bern and people at Oregon State University agreed
that that was important.
It sounded like President Bern was crucial to this process
happening in the first place within the office,
and we're running around and working with his perspective as well as in the community.
Well, Paul Rissard didn't have much to do with it mechanistically
because he signed the memorandum of understanding,
because by the time that document was generated,
John Bern was leaving his president.
So, Paul Rissard was the incoming president.
And I think there were a lot of press releases that about that time as well.
So, Paul Rissard had to respond as the new face of Oregon State University
about this move of the one that's playing in the institute and so forth.
But his scientific training I believe was as a botanist.
So, he probably had less appreciation for Pauling scientific work
than maybe people in the other biological sciences or in the physical sciences
like physics and chemistry.
He certainly was aware of line as Pauling,
but I think this was basically John Bern's baby.
And Dick Scanlan at that time assumed a really pivotal role,
a very important role in helping the institute to integrate into Oregon State University.
So, Paul Rissard was certainly aware of everything
and very supportive of everything,
but did not play a really pivotal role early on.
It was really Dick Scanlan.
It was working very hard in this area.
What were you doing in this one question that we did at Rissard?
Well, I'll be frank.
My initial impressions were not great.
I had spent my life in the East Coast near Boston
and at Stanford near San Francisco,
which was a hive of activity, intellectual, cultural activity,
academic activity.
So, it can value here virgin during my time there.
So, it was a very dynamic and kind of thrilling
and overstimulating type of environment that I'd grown to love.
So, coming up here to Corvallis.
Corvallis struck me as a very sleepy town in those days.
Didn't seem to have a big bookstore in town.
Didn't seem to have many movie theaters.
Didn't seem to have a lot of good restaurants.
And to be honest, it surprised me.
Because here's a college town with tens of thousands of students
and a lot of faculty who were very bright and energetic.
And I was surprised that that kind of energy
and intellectual dynamism, which I'm sure existed here in campus,
didn't translate into more that I could perceive in town.
So, nevertheless, I felt that this was the best option for the Institute
and I felt compelled from a professional standpoint to work very hard
to ensure that the Institute was a success.
Because, like Linus Paul and Junior, we didn't really want to see this fail
and see what could become a really successful working tribute
to Linus Paul and turning into a disaster.
So, I felt personally and professionally committed to making this work.
And I realized that it was probably imperative for me to become part of this process
and moving from California to Oregon, at least initially,
to get the Institute up and running and make sure that everything was
happening appropriately and that we didn't really lose sight
of the reason that the Institute existed in the first place.
Namely, the study of worth and molecular medicine.
I was a little surprised at kind of the Perocule,
and kind of provincial attitude of some of the faculty here at Oregon State,
nutrition and so forth.
It seemed to be a little old fashioned to me.
But I thought the Institute would probably settle in and do quite well.
And there were a number of faculty who were extraordinarily bright
and excited about the Institute being here,
and they were the ones that we were going to be working with.
So, I felt very good about that.
But I was concerned really about my own personal satisfaction here in Corvalle.
I mean, I know that the ocean is an hour and a half away
and the mountains are an hour and a half away.
And Portland is an hour away.
But everything's at least an hour away.
And in Palo Alto, I was very right in the midst of things.
San Francisco is a short train ride, half hour by car at that.
So I was concerned about that.
Corvalle has changed quite a lot over the years as well.
Do you mention Dick's talent?
Dick's talent was an important early ally.
Was it important in terms of being made to prevent rate it?
I think George Bailey was very important as well.
He was an environmental and molecular tax college,
and director of the Marine freshwater biomedical sciences center at the time.
Using trout as a model to study carcinogenesis,
and he'd been part of this committee that had been set up by Dick's kin
and John Burns to sort of investigate the Association of the Institute
with OSU.
Also Chris Matthews, who is the chairman of the department
of biochemistry and bio physics, I think, played a very important role.
And part of the reason these people were important was that new faculty
coming into the Institute, which was essential,
were going to have their academic homes in different departments
across campus, and maybe even in different colleges across campus.
So it was very important for the Institute to be well integrated
and be close to these departmental chairs and deans,
as well.
John Leon plays a very important role early on in Tim White.
I think was involved as well.
I can't remember all the people who constituted the search committee
for the director, but a number of those people were also on the search committee.
And we took that job extremely seriously and reviewed numerous applications
and wittled the field down to a number of really outstanding candidates.
And then set about presenting each member of the search committee presented to candidates.
And the choice was overwhelming for Ballsry, which was terrific.
Also Phil Wanger, who was, I believe, an environmental molecular toxicology
working on selenium at that time.
It was also someone who was closely associated with me as a student.
The higher ball is, but I expect you to have a relationship moment.
It really was.
Hiring Ballsry, who was working, of course, on vitamin C, was very strategic.
He's a terrific scientist.
He had terrific recommendations from Bruce A.M.,
who was a national academy, a science member, and winner of the...
What is the award that Paul Engut from Gerald Ford?
The National Medal of Science, winner as well.
Excuse me.
So Bruce A.M.s recommended him extremely strongly.
And Balls had had...
We knew him as well, or at least I had known him for a few years,
since his parents to give a seminar at the Institute back in California.
And he had, after leaving, Bruce A.M.s lab as a postdoc.
It Berkeley, he'd gone to Harvard, had a position there,
and was currently at Boston University School of Medicine,
doing work on vitamin C and atherosclerosis.
So we felt that it would be terrific for the Institute to get him,
because we would ensure central importance of worth of molecular medicine,
and coincidentally, when a Paul Engut's favorite molecules vitamin C
would have a very prominent place in the Institute's research,
and Ballsry would be a really terrific director.
And then with the faculty lines and startup packages,
created by OSU, the research office,
I think that really was an exciting time,
and that really showed that we now had a mechanism for moving forward.
We weren't going to have to be completely dependent on fundraising
from our donors in order to make the Institute a success.
Now we're going to be able to bring in high caliber faculty
because of these faculty lines.
And when those people were recruited, things were always started to,
of course, progress pretty dramatically.
So you're letting your hired Tori Hagen, Merit Trader, and Rod Dashwood?
That's right.
So the backbone of research back on the links that you don't figure
and out as you know.
That's right.
That was very, those were all very good decisions.
Tori now is director of our Healthy Aging Program,
Rod Dashwood is director of the Cancer Chemical Protection Program.
Rod had been here previously to work with George Bailey many,
many years ago, and is one of the leading researchers
and phytochemicals and cancer in the world.
So that was a very important part of our research program.
And Merit Trader, coming up from UC Berkeley from Lester Packers Lab,
one of the world's authorities on vitamin E.
So we thought that the combination of Tori Hagen,
working on AG Central Micronutrients, Rod working
in phytochemical protection against Carson Agenesis,
and Merit working in molecular mechanisms of vitamin E,
another very important physiological antioxidant,
and then balts for eye working on vitamin C,
would really constitute a great attack in some of these problems
that had interested in line as part.
I think it's probably safe to say that.
I think balts impressed all of them.
Of course Merit Trader, new balts already from their
prior association at UC Berkeley.
But I think his acumen and abilities in energy
and reputation as a scientist were really critical
in attracting these other candidates who were hired.
And that there are these four people's ability to successfully
attract trans-configure them through this.
That's right.
It's always been a consideration, a major consideration
for becoming a principal investigator in the Institute
and being selected from the enormously large pool of qualified candidates,
the ability to support a research program through NIH,
or NCI funding, or independent funding,
is can't be understated, and it's absolutely critical
to be considered for a position like that.
And to achieve success in that kind of funding
on a regular basis, I think, speaks very well
with a caliber of any candidate who's selected for that position.
David Williams, when I actually wrote that.
David Williams was doing a very good work here
in environmental and molecular toxicology,
and also had a assumed directorship
of the Marine Freshwater Biomedical Sciences Center.
So he also was very interested in photochemical protection
against Carson and Genesis, which fit right into the Institute's mission.
And he's been a principal investigator all this time as well.
He was not recruited extra merely.
He was at OSU George Bailey, of course,
continued to remain as a professor at OSU
and just retired a few years ago.
And I think within very fortunate that none of the faculty
we've recruited has left for a better job
any place else, so I think it shows that the Institute
has become a collegial and productive home for people
where they feel good about their ability
to carry out their research programs,
and like their colleagues.
At some point, the Institute changed its name
and the line is calling into the science medicine
to just want the Institute to work to comment on the reason why.
Yeah, well that's kind of the two organizations overlapped.
So the Institute as a five on one C3 incorporated
in the state of California was known from 1973 or four on
as the Linus Poly Institute of Science and Medicine.
The Institute as it exists here at Oregon State University
has always been known as the Linus Poly Institute
and was independent from the Linus Poly Institute of Science and Medicine.
When the Institute moved here,
we transferred, as I said, our financial assets, physical assets
and some personnel to establish the Linus Poly Institute
at Oregon State University,
but the shell organization continued to be viable
in the state of California for actually quite a few years after that.
And there were a number of reasons for that.
One reason was we wanted to continue to be
the recipient of bequests that names
specifically the Linus Poly Institute of Science and Medicine.
And there were a couple of bequests in the offing
in which the executors and attorneys handling the estate
weren't sure that they could recognize Oregon State University
of the Oregon State University Foundation as the successor
to the Linus Poly Institute of Science and Medicine.
So we thought rather than imperial any of these large bequests
and there were several that were quite large
that it would just be best to continue that shell organization
that could be recipient of some of these funds and bequests.
There were also legal issues that needed to be tied up
to its litigation with Rexie Gerawala
about wrongful termination that needed to be resolved.
And there were, let's see, mainly financial and legal issues
that were still dangling.
Yeah, everybody in California, as I might have mentioned,
was at Will that was employment status.
And it's very popular and playing with the same
organization.
And it's very popular and playing with the same organization.
It would have been nice to offer people long-term contracts,
but it really was not economically feasible to do that.
We're prudent because the Institute had no reliably safe source
of chronic funding.
We didn't have an endowment and, as you know, as you're well aware,
the income was up and down over the years.
And it was a great opportunity for us to be able to
continue that policy.
But it really was really no way to move to any other kind of policy
at that time.
But it mainly benefits the employer, not the employee.
And I feel terrible about continuing that policy.
But there was really no way to move to any other kind of policy
at that time.
And I think that's a very important thing.
It's a very important way to move to any other kind of policy
at that time in Palo Alto.
And of course, the Linus Poly Institute of Science in Medicine
really had no absolute influence on which employees
from that organization would be offered jobs
by Oregon State University.
So the Linus Poly Institute of Science in Medicine
was not making job offers to its own employees
to come to Corvallis to take a position.
The Linus Poly Institute University was making those offers.
So when it became clear which staff members in Palo Alto
would be offered jobs and which weren't offered jobs,
then the people who were not going to be offered jobs,
some had made a decision, some resigned made a decision
that they didn't want to go to Oregon anyway.
And some were laid off.
The Federal Reserve Waterwall of Intern sued the Institute
for Wrongful Termination.
And that was another one of the zazz standing.
Excuse me, litigations that was a reason
when the Institute could not go out of business right away.
So there was an old, there was a period of overlap.
There was Linus Poly Institute, here at Oregon State University.
And there was a continuing Sheller organization in California.
Institute of Science and Medicine. Another reason was that we had entered into a contract with
Arden and Unilever, and that contract with the Linus Plan Institute of Science and Medicine.
So there were lots of complicated legal and financial issues that all of us agreed seem
to be resolved by just keeping the Institute a shell organization until all these loose ends
could be tied up. And then that finally was achieved about 2005, 2003, 2005. I can't remember
the exact year, but that's finally when the Institute went through legal dissolution and transferred
remaining assets to Oregon State University Foundation. So I served kind of two roles. I served
continuing to serve as the Chief Executive Officer of LPSM, and then also the Administrator
of Officer for LPI here at Oregon State University.
In 2000, one of your more interesting and successful sort of public outreach efforts for
Secretary of Information Center came online. I wanted to talk about that a little bit. One thing
interesting and looking at it is that by that point, the Institute of Science and Medicine
is definitely back the way from the negative points that I've been seeing since I've been getting
40 milligrams of far-cracked employees. I was talking about these active memories,
we got left through the conversation behind that. Sure. Well, there's never been a litmus test
for employment at the Linus Plan Institute, even in California, and people have different
behavior as far as supplementation goes. So there are people in California at the Institute
who took large doses of vitamin C and vitamin E and multivitaments. There were people who didn't
take supplemental vitamins. So it's never been a litmus test, and nobody has ever been forced
to tell the party line about vitamins supplements. Everybody's free to make up their own mind
about what to do and what to recommend and so forth. I think the scientists associated with
the Linus Plan Institute that came on board here in Oregon all had without fail.
Chimentus respect for Linus Polling, but probably as good scientists were a little skeptical
of the enormous mega doses that Polling advocated and therefore weren't comfortable in recommending
these kinds of doses themselves because they either hadn't done the research to convince them
that these the magnitude of these doses was warranted in each and every case or, you know,
that's my guess as they just weren't familiar with a lot of Polling's arguments about this.
So the Micron Engineering Information Center came about in the year 2000. I think partly as a result
of conversations at early retreats and also feedback from the scientific advisory board
about the Institute being a resource for peer reviewed, scientifically accurate, and updated
information on the role of micronutrients including vitamins and minerals and phytochemicals and
dietary constituents in preventing disease, treating disease when applicable, and also in
taining optimum health. We had an idea somewhat similar to this on a more limited scale back in
California where we had talked about becoming a resource for a worldwide resource for vitamin C
information specifically because we had some expertise in vitamin C obviously through Linus Polling
and other staff members and we had talked about that if there was some way to become a resource for
that kind of information and again this was before the internet had really taken off so
it would have required hiring people with more knowledge about nutrition and molecular biology
and the intersection between nutrition and molecular biology and medicine and we just didn't
have the funds to do that at that time and it was also probably not prudent because there was a
lot of uncertainty about the future of the Institute so it would have been full hard to set up a new
program only to lose it with the move of the Institute to a new location or the liquidation of
the Institute or something like that so we never acted on that dream at that time but then this
kind of resurfaced in a broader sense before the year 2000 and the idea then of course the internet
had really taken off to make this an electronic electronically accessible database and we started
thinking about who would be appropriate to set up and manage such a database and we felt
somebody with a PhD in nutrition or in molecular biology related to nutrition and somebody with
some computer skills would be required to do this so at that time Jane Higden had just gotten a PhD
in nutrition from Oregon State University and was not interested in pursuing a career and experimental
science wasn't really interested in securing a tenure-track position in academia but was interested
in staying in the scientific realm so she applied for that position and she was perfectly suited for it
she had had experience as a nurse in New York City that she got a nursing degree from Pacy University
and had gotten an undergraduate degree in biology from Stanford so she was quite smart and had
great experience and was willing to take on this task of setting up our marketing and training
information center and we also hired somebody to work with her who could do the initial computer work
and software that was required to get this up and running excuse me so the two of them
collaborated on this and over the years it's developed into quite an astonishing resource and to the extent that
when we thought about updating Pauling's book had a live longer and feel better and this is
something that Pauling himself had pursued back in the 80s and he'd signed a contract with Brian
Leibowitz as a matter of fact to work on an update of how to live longer and feel better but
I think they had a disagreement about the strategy there and the scope of the work and that
really came to not but Linus Poon Jr and I were very interested in getting a new addition of how to
live longer and feel better published and we talked to a number of people that we thought would be
good candidates including Gladys Block we wanted somebody who was sympathetic to Pauling's ideas and
worth them a lot in the medicine but also extremely knowledgeable and kept up with the literature
and so forth to find someone to do that who already has a productive research career is really
difficult and we weren't able to locate anyone to carry out that work and then with the
advent of our micro-neutune information center it occurred to me that that was really an electronic
update of Pauling's book because now we were continuing to stay abreast of all the research
information in worth a molecular medicine and instead of compiling into a book it was online
so we decided when the prospect of publishing an anniversary edition of how to live longer and feel
better came up and I approached Oregon State University press about that we we decided to keep the
book intact addbacks some illustrations and other work that had been deleted because when the
book went from trade paper back size on nice paper to mass market paper back size on course paper
some of the resolution of the typos lost and some of the illustrations just weren't appropriate
so they were deleted from that mass market paper back edition we wanted to bring those back
and decided that the best way of doing this new edition of the book which would be the 20th
anniversary edition would be to have a new forward written and afterward kind of put the working
context with on the basis of new research that had been done since the book was first published in
1986 and also makes some judicious annotations where people that Pauling refers to for instance
in the present tense who have died maybe indicate that the people have died or if the RDAs
changed maybe indicate why the RDAs changed or the UL and things like that so we really limited
to tinkering with the text to annotations and then providing some more text at the beginning and end
of the book and then directing people in the afterward to visit the micronutrient information center
because that really provides an update of how to live longer and feel better and over the years
as the number of chapters grew in that micronutrient information center and it became
and was always widely accessible through search engines it's becoming enormously popular
so recently it's been getting on on the order of 20 to 25 million hits per year
and most of those of course are not local there are all over the country all over the world
and it's been a terrific resource for people to use in consulting with their physicians about
health problems or to find out more about the biochemical or physiological action of some of
these important micronutrients the emphasis in the micronutrient information center has always been on human health
so we will revert to discussing cell culture or animal studies when there doesn't seem to be
much human data available but the focus is really our humans because humans are the ones that are
reading this there the ones that are interested in applying this information to their own health
and that's been the focus and the information that has been written by Jane Higden
and she was succeeded by Dr. Victoria Drake and now we have another person working with
Victoria Drake on the micronutrient information center, Johnna, Angelo all the articles that they
are sent out to leading experts in the field for peer review and then they're periodically updated
as well to take into account new information new studies that might cause the institute to
modify its recommendations so the end of each of these chapters ends with the one is applying
recommendation and in many cases it's very similar to or the same as the DRIs that the food nutrition
board publishes in some cases it's different and in the case of vitamin C for instance it's different
we don't recommend the enormous quantities that line is applying recommended in part because
pharmacokinetic studies and molecular studies have revealed that the amount of vitamin C absorbed
from a gut into the bloodstream is limited by the sodium vitamin C transporters which are
relatively newly discovered they hadn't been discovered by the time Pauling died but they are
known now and it explains why only a fraction of a very small dose of vitamin C gets from the gut
into the bloodstream it's limited it's controlled by these vitamin C transporters so it just doesn't
diffuse you know against a gradient or something it really is limited so practically speaking
and biochemically it doesn't make sense to take a huge dose of vitamin C because only a small
fraction of that will be absorbed so we decided on the basis of meta analyses on basis of biochemical
epidemiological studies that it's important to keep bloodloves of vitamin C very high that produce
not really saturation but very high concentrations in circulating cells in the blood and also
cells in different tissues because vitamin C is very important and non-toxic so we recommend now
to get at least 400 milligrams a day so by saying at least 400 milligrams a day we recognize
that it's important to get much more than what the RDA is for instance and we also recognize implicitly
the safety of high dose vitamin C so we don't specifically recommend many grams a day but we
recognize also that high dose vitamin C is very safe as a matter of fact the UL which is the
upper tolerable upper level of intake for vitamin C was established in 2000 and at 2000 milligrams
per day based solely on the transient laxative effect of higher doses in some people which is really
not a serious side effect it's not really pathological or toxic and is the argument in favor of
the intravenous vitamin C in the possible therapeutic procedure that does that still a little
of the question well actually that's been greatly reinvigorated by some of these pharmacokinetic
studies after the male clinic studies as we discussed there was kind of a dismissal of vitamin C
utility of vitamin C as a therapeutic agent in cancer and a lot of oncologists and physicians
became very uninterested in vitamin C's pedestrian molecule it's already been studied by
the male clinic it's failed so therefore it's time to move on however pharmacokinetic studies
that really demonstrated very clearly in these transport studies and molecular biology
have something my throat showed that when you give vitamin C intravenously you get much higher
concentrations in the blood then you do when you take it orally depending upon the dose given
intravenously you can end up with millimolar concentrations in the blood when you take vitamin C
orally it's tough to get above about 200 micromole per liter in the blood concentration so millimole
you're talking about 70 or a hundred times greater concentration of vitamin C when given intravenously
and that led people conducting these pharmacokinetic studies to think more carefully about
why cameras work with Pauling was so successful in Scotland and why the male clinics work
in Minnesota failed and it's pretty clear that these these high levels of vitamin C exhibit
cytotoxicity selective cytotoxicity against tumor cells and this has been shown in
cell culture experiments for many many many years and even in the early 1980s Pauling himself
published with Japanese colleagues a paper showing that vitamin C had cytotoxicity against
tumor cells in culture and that this was completely nullified by the addition of catalysts
to the culture medium and catalysts of course quenches hydrogen peroxide so they surmides that the
cytotoxicity was due to vitamin C acting as a prooxinant and generating hydrogen peroxide
which was then killing tumor cells so this very mechanism was then rediscovered many years later
and shown to occur when you get these pharmacological concentrations of vitamin C in the blood
when given intravenously it starts generating hydrogen peroxide which attacks tumor cells and it seems
to be very selective either normal cells are protected by endogenous antioxidants or some other
protective mechanism as it play and that led to renewed interest in the prospect of using
high dose IV vitamin C as a junctive therapy and cancer and there have been many many
anecdotal studies published case histories published in a couple of phase one clinical trials published
as well so I think there's quite a lot of interest now but there are also quite a lot of issues
that need to be much more fully characterized for instance which types of human cancer are
most sensitive to these high concentrations of vitamin C which patients are the best candidates for
high dose vitamin C at what stage of cancer can vitamin C be given with chemotherapy
of drugs in a synergistic manner would vitamin C negate the effect of some types of chemotherapy
of drugs should it be used in connection with radiotherapy and what would be the optimum
protocol for administration of vitamin C for instance Cameron you with his terminally
old patient population these people were hospitalized waiting to die so he could give continuous
slow drip intravenous vitamin C high dose vitamin C hour after hour day after day so
retrospectively you're thinking about this and thinking that hydrogen peroxide must have been
rather continuously generated and rather continuously attacking these tumor cells in vivo
for many patients now who get high dose IV vitamin C it's given in a periodic fashion two
or three times a week for a high doses so hydrogen peroxide is being generated transiently
and then after four to six hours the level of vitamin C in the blood is right back at baseline
no more hydrogen peroxide generation presumably so those kinds of issues whether it's okay to
have periodic generation or hydrogen peroxide through a kind of intermittent IV vitamin C use or whether
this continuous generation hydrogen peroxide is more effective all these issues are very
nuanced and difficult and I think have to be really thoroughly characterized before will
really understand the merits of vitamin C against cancer but there are people that are actively
working in that area and they recognize all these issues in 2001 against the two hosts of its first
diet and not coming to health conference and that also came with the first health guidance for health
research which is a $50,000 price pretty remarkable turnaround for an organization that was
either have a break going out of business really amazing turnaround and part of that has to do with
I think Rick Hicks cultivation of donors over the years by always putting information about
bequest and plan gifts in the periodic newsletter that went out to our constituents so people were
aware from the mid 70s on and named the Institute in their wills and those bequest that came in
very irregularly and unpredictably to the Institute allowed us to do really wonderful things including
a doubt endowing new faculty positions within the Institute convening things like the diet not
them of health conference and giving that prize for health research and also the the fact that the
cost of doing business here at Oregon State was much less because we weren't having to pay rent
any longer we weren't having to pay people to participate in a large fundraising program or pay
a controller and bookkeeper and so forth so a lot of the activities that had to be supported
as an independent organization did not have to be supported in this context of Oregon State
University so costs were were down and therefore the bequest in the money that was coming in could
be could be applied towards growth of the Institute instead of just merely sustaining the Institute.
Also in 2001 Joe Beckman arrived at the Institute talking over about the background behind that
and the fact that he is working ALS into sort of opening up a different angle research for the Institute.
That's right there always been interest of course in neurodegenerative diseases at the Institute and
we were looking for a candidate who could open up that new area of research and Joe Beckman was
one who applied and he'd done some really outstanding work on molecular work on ALS in Birmingham,
Alabama at the University of Alabama. Showing that proxy nitrate is a very interesting
destructive molecule that is generated through the evolution of nitric oxide in the body
very damaging molecule so his work really appealed to us reactive nitrogen species was kind of a new
avenue of research reactive oxygen species work of course have been undertaken by many
people all around the world for many years including some at LPI but reactive nitrogen species was
kind of a new a new facet of this that would be very interesting pursue and he was given the
a the hell in Pauling in dad position because we thought it would be would be nice to honor
Linus Pauling's wife with another with the second in dad position and at that time we had the
money thanks to be quests in order to do that and also some of the money that came into the
Institute at that time was not just from the quest but also from legal actions as an example
when the insurance companies refused to reimburse us for legal expenses during the
wrath litigation I decided to sue the insurance companies because they weren't honoring our claims
and they made up reasons why you know they couldn't honor the claims but nevertheless or
commercial liability and directors and officers insurance I thought would apply and that was
shock that they refused honor these claims so we decided to sue them and that was settled before
going to trial and that resulted in quite a large amount of money coming to me as to as well so we had
money coming in from a number of different avenues that allowed us to adapt these positions
It took a couple more questions we talked about the principal investigators and balls
I wanted to do any of their folks that have been making the years and the last 10 years
or so I'm sort of trying to have to do well I think clearly the people who were operating the
research office were have been very important because ball supply reports to the head of the
research office and the money is that are available through returned overhead and through
through the research office have been very important to me as to do it over the years
the deans and departmental chairs have also been extraordinarily important
because when candidates are being interviewed and reviewed for faculty position within the
institute as a principal investigator institute they have to have an academic home as well
which means that the chairperson of the appropriate academic unit in his or her colleagues and
faculty members have to vote on whether or not this candidate were fined into their department
so it's a very convoluted and entwined process of selecting someone for the institute and for
an academic department so although the departmental heads have been quite important as well
that was your job change everything
well my job has changed in so far as I obviously am no longer the chief executive officer in
the line is pulling us to the science and medicine which was kind of a parallel track for me
and once that was finally legally dissolved and I didn't have to think about that any longer
basically could focus on my responsibilities as administrative officer for the institute
and from the when we first moved here I took over editorship of the newsletter because we
recognized that the newsletter continued to be an important educational tool and fundraising tool
from the institute and I thought I could do it and and Don Reed thought I could do it so I just
started to do that unilaterally and that's been a lot of fun we have historically given out
pilot project grants to fund initial research by people doing work related to the institute
of the mission in order to allow them to obtain enough data to apply for larger more sustaining
grants from say NCI or NIH and the work that they've done has always been reported in the newsletter
so talking with those people getting asking them for articles for the newsletter editing those
articles trying to translate that information from a very technical language to language it's
a little more friendly to the casual reader has been a lot of my responsibility and then of course
pursuing this option of a new building for the institute has been something that Paul's Ryan had been
working on right from the beginning very diligently and then when the funding finally came together
for that even before the funding came together we spent quite a lot of time talking to architects
and visiting buildings and so forth trying to get a clearer idea of what it was we wanted
and also to provide us with material that could be shown to prospective donors so we wanted to have
a good idea of what the institute could look like with the new building could look like
and have something that we could show to people a visual representation of this a model or something like that
so he and I worked very closely on not all that work and I became a member of the steering committee
for the Lines Pong Science Center so I'd say for the last couple of years two or three years I've been working
very intensively with user groups trying to identify issues that needed to be incorporated
into the design and given to the architects to design our building and also there's always been
a bit of a fundraise and component to my position as well because I have such a long history
with the institute and I know about a lot of our past activities and I knew line is
calling pretty well I'm often asked by our fundraiser or other groups the rotary club
blinds club different groups here at Oregon State University and elsewhere to give talks on
Pauling or worth a molecular medicine or to provide overviews of the research that's going on at
the institute now and I rather often in two or three times a year travel to scientific or medical
conferences to make presentations on Pauling or with a molecular medicine and to give those kinds of
updates well it's just such a terrific change for the institute one of her as I said was completely
satisfactory in the early days for the institute but as the institute grew we became very fragmented
because we had faculty in different buildings all over campus and it became less and less likely to
interact with fellow faculty who were part of the institute and of course I think that decreases
the collegiality and also diminishes the prospect for good meaningful scientific interactions on a
frequent basis that could generate new ideas and make progress and research projects so
the new building has allowed almost all the institute principal investigators to be housed together now
Joe Beckman is still in ALS but it's just a stone's throw from the line is point science center which is
next to Nash which is the building that sits between ALS and the line is point science center so he's
still physically very close to the institute all along not part of the building itself and being in a very
spacious well lit modern building with open lab space and modular space that's quite flexible
is just such a such a wonderful inspiration for everyone in the interaction with your colleagues
now is dramatically increased as well because all the offices are aligned along the north wall
on the third floor in the fourth floor and there's an open atrium kind of a cathedral
esque environment between the third and fourth floor a staircase in the middle there allows people to get
from one floor to the other so there's just this feeling of openness and integration that is really
wonderful now you've received this milestone is building what now is the next set of priorities
what's the problem with the next set of priorities I think are to expand and develop our
micometrine information center also work on a new program in our outreach which is called the
healthy youth program which is trying to introduce the concepts of good nutrition and lifestyle
among elementary school children and middle school children so that kids can get a good
idea as about how to stay healthy when they're young in terms of exercise and eating well
and also we still have the ability to recruit more faculty for our healthy aging program
once we recruit more faculty for our healthy aging program I think we'll be saturated with respect to
four principal investigators per area having labs in the one as pong institute
four that's the end of my questions are there any things we didn't cover that come to mind
off and if we should talk about inspired by the Institute there it was you were afraid of that
it's gonna like be bad in this question probably but I can't think of anything off here and so let me
think about that